what you wouldn't see is any evidence at
all that humans have noticed climate
[Music]
change I'm just going to start by
looking at the kind of physical
dimensions of the challenges that we
face so here it is I'm just going to
give a very very quick sort of taste of
it just to map out a few of them we've
obviously got a climate emergency and an
and an energy transition that's you know
really strongly linked to that and I'll
say just a couple of words about that in
a minute
whilst we deal with all that we've got a
biodiversity challenge which is actually
just as serious but it doesn't get
anything like the air time and while we
deal with that of course we've got the
little detail of we've got to uh we've
got to feed everybody in and the
population Rising while we're at it and
we've got to do that whilst dealing with
the incredible amount of every kind of
pollution you can think of um Plastics
is one of them but a ton a ton of other
pollutants as well uh and of course
we've been hearing and feeling a lot
about disease threat that we've we've
also got so it's a kind of you know it's
a lot of things to deal with all at once
and one of the things we got to get a
lot better at is joining up our thinking
on all of that before I go any further
I've got some this is going to be is it
an optimistic talk I think it's in a way
it's an optim I hope it's an optimistic
talk depends on where your start point
is if your start point is that you think
we're basically fine and it's we can we
can carry on those environmentalists
have always banged on a bit and it's
always been fine to broadly speaking
ignore them and decade after decade
always fine if that's where you're
coming from then this is not an
optimistic talk if where you're coming
from is that we are you you've convinced
yourself that the situation is hopeless
and humans are just fundamentally so
messed up that we can't possibly get
through this then I think I I I think
this is an optimistic talk but the
headline on all this stuff is that uh it
turns out that from a science and
technology point of view we've got the
solutions I'm not I don't want to
belittle how complex and how difficult
it is to implement them but if it was
only about working through uh with good
intention what the Science and
Technology were telling us about these
problems and and finding the solutions
you know we'd do it we'd be right on top
of all of this so I've left a load of
space in the middle to talk about what's
maybe the Crux of the problem but before
we get into it I before we get into the
middle stuff I'm just going to give a
few words on some of the stuff some of
the words in green there so first up a
little bit on energy and climate so
there's the there's the global energy
use curve that's going up and up up at
it's 2.4% per year that's taken us to
such a dangerous dangerous position and
one of the things we hear a lot from
from the fossil fuel companies at the
moment is they're talking about you know
well you know they're helping us to deal
with humankind's Rising energy demand
you know Rising energy needs and that
that needs a complete reframe we don't
we don't have Rising energy needs
humankind can get get away with using a
lot less energy than we use today even
though there are some parts of the world
that actually need to use um that
actually probably have a just a good
case for using more more energy but here
in the in the UK for example we can get
away with using a lot less uh lot a lot
less energy than we do at the moment and
we're all the time we're getting
efficiency improvements but we're not
bagging the savings from
them okay I just want to highlight a
couple of things about this carbon curve
that's just carbon emissions from fossil
fuel use so if you were on Mars looking
at data about Earth asking yourself how
are humans getting on what's been their
story for the last few years you would
notice a few things you'd notice that
there was a you'd notice we've had some
events in the in in the last in the last
um 30 years or so you'd notice the
dissolution of the Soviet Union you'd
notice a little dip for a global
financial crisis you'd notice the
biggest you'd notice a little temporary
dip for the pandemic but what you
wouldn't see is any evidence at all that
humans have noticed climate change and
I'm you know I'm not saying this uh to
be pessimistic because I'm because by
noticing this it tells us a lot about
what does and doesn't solve the problem
so you could argue this looks as though
it might be tailing off but if you do
the maths and stats on it there's no
statistical significance in that at all
it's entirely consistent with emissions
going um up and up and up up you know on
a on a rising curve that's been
averaging 1.8% per year in a remarkably
mathematically exponential way for about
160 years uh at least so why is that
because we all know I bet this room is
full of people who try and cut their
carbon at least sometimes and the the
government's talking about stuff and I
work with loads of businesses that got
targets how come you can't see any faint
you can't see a trace of a dent in that
curve yet well unfortunately it's to do
with the the Dynamics of how
of how things are working at the moment
and you could call it sometimes call it
the balloon squeezing effect or the
rebound effect but the way that the
Dynamics work is that if you try and
deal with climate change by just sort of
squeezing the carbon emissions in a few
places at once what happens is
unfortunately it creates a tendency for
the slack to get taken up elsewhere in
other words you know if you cut your
carbon footprint and that's all you do
the reality is it creates a tenden for
someone else to have a bit of a bigger
carbon footprint and the real and the
sum total of it all so far is nothing
I'm not saying that to mean don't bother
trying to be responsible with your with
your own personal carbon emissions I do
think that's part of what we can all do
but what I'm saying is that somehow we
need to do it in such a way that we're
helping to create the conditions under
which the whole balloon can be squeezed
at once in other words the whole of
humanity can bring about a systemic a Sy
systemic change um that leaves the
fossil fuel in the ground and deals with
all the other environmental issues that
we've got as well which takes us onto
the kind of real heart of the question
because none of this is rocket science
at all so far and you know this is the
most fascinating bit of it all of course
is the is the human reaction to it to be
optimistic I think the evidence that we
might slowly slowly be getting to the
point where we're suddenly ready to wake
up is stronger a lot stronger than it
was maybe two or three maybe two or 3
years
ago okay more more optimistic stuff I
said that the science from a science and
technology perspective uh we could we
could do this so I know this is a bit
simplistic but that dot is the scale and
it represents the size of the solar
panels that we would need to replace the
whole of Today's Energy Supply and it's
about 200 and something Miles by 200 and
something miles now clearly there's a
lot of devil in the detail we've got to
produce the solar panels and that's got
uh that's got an environmental cost and
not everybody has sunlight and the sun's
not always shining and somehow you've
got to get it to everybody when they
need it where they need it uh and so
there's other technologies that we need
like hydrogen and wind and a whole load
of different stuff but when you look at
all of those and the first kind of fifth
there's about 50 pages in no Planet B
devoted to that stuff it all turns out
to be broadly speaking doable but just
to illustrate I said that it's no good
uh it's no
good uh if our energy Supply is is still
Rising if we stay on the the rate at
which we're growing our energy use at
the
moment um that's what it looks like now
that's what it would look like in 100
years we'd need 10 of those dots in 200
years we'd need 100 of those dots and in
300 years we need every single scrap of
land in the world to be covered in solar
panels and you couldn't have a human
with sunlight landing on them because
that would be casting a shadow on a
solar panel that we'd need for our
energy Supply so it's just a kind of an
illustration but you know I get
depressed in a way when I see Renewables
uh going up at the moment because they
are actually doing us no good whatever
they only do us good if they replace the
fossil fuel and the evidence is that you
know it doesn't happen on its own what
you need to separately do is come to an
arrangement to constrict the carbon
emissions we actually need to uh
something separate to leave the fuel in
the ground which is SK so obvious but um
we still we still gloss over with you
know um climate policies that are all
about Renewables but actually don't deal
with um making sure the fuel stays in
the
ground okay um so the big the big
renewable uh energy source is is
sunlight the other ones are in there but
they're not as important so let's have a
look at who gets that sunlight because
in this carb low carbon transition we're
going to have the problem of sharing uh
which I'll talk about slightly in a
moment so this map is to scale it's a
squidgy map
and so the size of each country is
represents how much sunlight lands on it
and the color scheme represents the
amount of sunlight per person dark is
good so there's Australia with 200 times
more sunlight per person than the UK
here's the UK looking very pale and
skinny up there we're the fifth worst
major country in the world for this
we're just ahead of Bangladesh Rwanda
Belgian and the Netherlands um in terms
of in terms of sunlight per person per
head but there's a whole question of how
we're going to share out the renewable
energy when we've got it this question
of how we're going to share is going to
be so critical because this is a global
problem uh so let's have a look you know
this is what this is who owns the fossil
fuel the top 10 countries with the 10
greatest fossil fuel reserves and I've
mapped up against it who's got the fos
who's got the sunlight and broadly
speaking they they match up quite nicely
actually it turns out not to be a
coincidence because if you think of how
how fossil fuels got formed it required
sunlight and so on um but there's still
this huge question of when we make that
transition how is that transition going
to be acceptable to all all these all
these countries and I think again to try
and be if there is there anything
optimistic we could say about Ukraine um
you know one of the big almost unas
difficult questions has always been well
how is the Russian fossil fuel ever
going to stay in the ground I mean
that's always been un it's still
incredibly difficult to come up with a a
way of imagining that taking place but
it feels to me it feels if anything
slightly more possible than it did um
than it did a few months
ago okay so that's all I want to say
about you know we could talk I could
talk for ages about most of these things
I just want to you know say about the
food and land system because in fact the
first 50 pages of of no Planet B is all
about that if you look at where we're up
to with the with the with the food
system I mean we are we are at the
moment uh if we could transition to far
less meat and dairy in our diet we could
liberate a lot of spare capacity uh for
looking after the biodiversity that
we're hemorrhaging and feeding a rising
population and dealing with climate
while we're at it uh and probably
getting on top of the fact that the
climate is changing making some land
less fertile and also we're degrading
land so quickly uh at the moment through
our current agricultural uh our our
current agricultural practices and
that's probably you know in terms of the
Science and Technology the food and land
stuff is probably the trickiest part of
the whole sustainability challenge but
it still feels doable okay so what would
it take for us to be solving these
technically solvable challenges and I
think my thinking on this is getting
simpler and simpler the more I the more
I think about it because I spend a lot
of time in debates about things like you
know really simple questions like should
the UK open up a new Coal Mine on the
west west coast of Cumbria I mean it's
you know it's so it's so clearcut and
yet the arguments for it get put in such
sophisticated ways and they're so
disingenuous and they're so hard to
unpick that I've wasted months of my
life on just that one question other
people have wasted even more time than
that and we you know there's something
going wrong it's not that the analysis
can't be done it's that something else
is happening to stop that analysis
getting acted on and that's what we've
really really got to uh that's what
we've really really got got to get on
top of to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I.V for more
debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas